I've got some really disturbing news
this by way of Vice news which is
reporting that neo-nazis are apparently
hijacking the left-wing anti-israel
protests you see many pro- Palestine
groups on the left groups such as black
lives matter are excusing and even
celebrating Hamas terrorists for
slaughtering Israeli civilians which is
totally fine according to the liberal
media but now the neo-nazis are doing
precisely the same thing which is evil
and Must Be Stopped hundreds of
thousands of liberals have been rallying
in cities around the world in support of
the Palestine Liberation movement and
against the state of Israel that
includes liberals that includes
islamists that includes all sorts of
people that are totally great according
to the Press but some neo-nazis have
joined them which is very bad even
though the neo-nazis are doing precisely
the same thing with the same rhetoric to
advance the same objectives it is bad
when they do it because they're white
and on the far right instead of brown
and in the mainstream left I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nolles
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Elon Musk says
that George Soros fundamentally hates
Humanity I'm sure he'll soon be called
an anti-semite because anytime you
criticize the most prominent left-wing
funer in the world people tell you that
you're you just hate the Jews or
something like that anyway we'll get to
that in just a moment first though this
word hijacking is really being used in
an interesting way here neo-nazis and
the Farr are trying to hijack the pro
Palestine what what is the point of the
pro pales
protests the the main Mantra that you
hear is from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free which means
abolishing the state of Israel which
plenty of people around the world want
to do including the neo-nazis there are
plenty of other people who also want to
do that and they're different groups but
they have the same objective so how is
it hijacking if if a group comes in and
and says hey you guys over there this
you distinct group we support what you
believe we are going to join with you in
the that you're currently performing and
we hope for the very same objectives
that you hope for how is that hijacking
hijacking is when you go in and you turn
a political movement toward some other
ends you subvert a political movement
here though it's just the same thing the
only difference is that when the brown
people do it Vice news says it's good
and when the white skin heads do it Vice
news says it's bad now if it call me
crazy call a some sort of wild
egalitarian but I think that an action
ought to be judged on its intrinsic
value rather than the shade of the
people who are performing such an action
but on the issue too the Israel
Palestine conflict what is the solution
the answer is there isn't one as Hamas
has made
clear Israel is a country with no place
in our land we must remove that country
because it constitutes a security
military and political
catastrophe to the Arab and Islamic
Nation we are not ashamed to say with
full force we must teach Israel a lesson
and we will do this again the aloa flood
is just the first time there will be a
second a third fourth that's referring
to the attack on October 7th because we
have the determination the resolve will
we have to pay a price yes and we are
ready to pay it we are called a nation
of Martyrs and we are proud to sacrifice
Martyrs we did not want to harm
civilians but there were complications
on the
ground the occupation must come to an
end occupation where in the Gaza Strip
no I'm talking about all the Palestinian
lands does that mean the annihilation of
Israel yes of course the existence of
Israel is illogical the existence of
Israel is what causes all that pain
Blood and
Tears it is Israel not us we are the
victims of the occupation period
therefore nobody should blame us for the
things we do on October
7th everything that we do is
Justified okay whatever one thinks of
the Israel Palestine conflict which
actually is a complex conflict that has
gone on in its present form for 100
years and has gone on in other forms for
Millennia at this point whatever one
thinks of the conflict the last part of
what he said there is not true ever
under any
circumstances the notion that anything
we do is Justified because of our
political claim that is not
true to the contrary there's something
called just war and there are two
Chief
considerations even within just War
which is is your action just when it
comes to going to war and is your action
just when you are already in war and
we've we've gone over on this show I
won't rehash it here we've gone over
some of what makes a war Justified going
All Through the Ages from great thinkers
including Cicero all the way up through
St Thomas aquinus and others all the way
up to the present that last part that he
he just said there is not true there are
in fact rules to war because there is
such a thing as the moral law and there
are moral considerations in war just as
there are in
peace what this does mean is that the
war is almost certainly intractable
because that the demands here cannot
really be resolved the pro Palestine
movement says that Israel's
establishment in 1948 constituted an
unjust Act of imperialism that the
British gave the Jews this land that
they had no right to give them and as a
result of this Palestinian Arabs were
were kicked out of their land into other
places and so they will just simply not
accept the existence of the state of
Israel Israel's argument is that God
gave us this land Millennia ago and
obviously different religious groups
have different views of what that
Covenant means Christians have a
different view Catholics and Orthodox
have a different view even then say
Evangelical Protestants and obviously
Jews have a different View and Muslims
have a different view so that's the the
ological argument and then the more
recent legal argument from the state of
Israel is that the balfor Declaration
grants the premise that the Jews can
establish a state in Israel and in 1948
the UN says it can happen and then an
even more recent argument from a
militarian political perspective is that
Israel will say we fought a war and it's
ours law of Conquest okay well then the
response to that is going to be okay
well we're going to keep making war on
you just like kamasa said here we're
going to just keep doing October 7th
we're going to keep attacking children
we're going to keep attacking women
we're going to keep attacking civilians
and there's going to be no end to it
which is very very sad it's a sad fact I
think there are some utopians out there
who believe that there's going to be a
once and for all answer to the Israel
Palestine conflict I just don't think
it's going to happen I guess Israel
could Annex Gaza formally Annex Gaza I I
don't think that the Arab states in the
region are going to take kindly to that
I don't think the West Bank is going to
take kindly to that I think it's
probably going to expand the war they
could glass Gaza same thing they could
try to send the gazans to Egypt I don't
I don't know that that's going to work
conversely Hamas could go in and say
we're going to kill all the Jews or
route them out of the land of Israel I
don't I don't think that's going to go
over all that well either so it's it it
seems relatively intractable now which
is why for the American audience my
perspective has always been and Remains
the chief us interest in this war is to
contain the war there's no no reasoning
with the head of Hamas okay there's no
reasoning with we celebrate our our
women and our children Martyrs to to die
so that we can abolish the state of
Israel there's no arguing with we love
death more than the Israelis love life
okay and there there's not going to be
any way what what's going to happen the
state of Israel is just going to say
okay never mind then we're gone we'll
we're going to leave we've been here for
75 years but ah okay we're done now
you're right Hamas you convinced us no
there's not so the the the only interest
for the United States or the chief
interest I should say is contain the war
we got to talk about these things and
when you want to talk you got to check
out pure talk right now go to peer
talk.com peer talk announced that they
would alleviate $10 million in veteran
debt by Veterans Day thanks to your
support these last few weeks Pure Talk
is 74% to that goal with two weeks to go
now just think about this we have a 100%
volunteer military men and women who
raise their hands to sacrifice for this
country and when they're done serving
they come back to a tight job market and
an outrageous cost of living expenses
that is why I am so happy a private
company like P talk has jumped into to
help when you switch to P talks
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service pure talks plans
start at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile hotspot just go to Pur talk.com
slns kwes make the switch let's rally
together show our unw support of our
veterans P talk.com switch to P talk
today it's the right move and it's the
American way speaking of containing
threats there's a new poll
out that looks at the race not just
Biden versus Trump not just Trump versus
the Republican primary candidates but
Biden versus Trump versus RFK Jr and
according to this poll forget about who
wins and who pulls votes from whom
according to this poll this is
Quinnipiac which is a very serious poll
are RFK Jr is currently polling at
22% against Biden and Trump so according
to this poll if it's just Biden versus
Trump Biden wins by one
point if it's Biden Trump and RFK Jr
Biden wins by three points so this
contradicts earlier polls I have long
said I think RFK takes more votes from
Biden than he does from Trump and most
polls have backed that up and I still
stand by that prediction this poll
contradicts that though albeit very
slightly and says no RFK actually takes
slightly more votes from Trump I I don't
totally buy that but could be the
case the crazier part about it is that
RFK Jr's at 22% so you got Biden at 39
Trump at 36 RFK Jr at 22 22 in that kind
of a race when the other two major party
Front Runners are in the 30s and you're
in the 20s that's crazy that's that's
really good and then what happens when
you had Cornell West into the race again
iak is predicting that Biden always wins
but then it goes down a little bit again
Biden is up one point it's Biden 36
Trump 35 so statistically even RFK Jr
loses a little bit at 19% and then
Cornell West is at 6% so according to
this Cornell the combination of Cornell
West and RFK Jr is better for Trump than
just RFK Jr himself again these are
pretty slim margins so forget about that
for a
second how does RFK Jr poll at 22% some
would say it's because he was right
about coid or at least he was more right
about coid than Anthony fouchy or Joe
Biden or maybe even Donald Trump for
that matter maybe but I don't think that
the RFK Jr support is primarily about Co
one because he's polling well among
Democrats I think he's at what 20% among
Democrats but also if the chief issue in
this race were coid and the handling of
coid Ronda santis would be the
Republican nominee not Donald Trump but
right now Trump is destroying Dan santis
according to this very same poll Trump
is at 64% ran DeSantis is at
15% so Trump is at more than
4X what disantis is and then DeSantis is
at roughly 2x what the next highest
polling Republican Nikki Haley's at
which is
8% so you got Trump with a 49 point
lead Ronda santis can claim maybe it's
his greatest achievement up there that
he was the best governor in America on
Co and yet he's losing so what's the RFK
Jr think about I think the RFK Jr 22%
surge in the polls is about a longing
for a bygone era I think it's not
because RFK Jr is the most normal guy in
the world but his last name's Kennedy
and he's more moderate at least on some
issues than Joe Biden he's more moderate
on immigration he's a he's a little more
moderate on abortion he's a little more
moderate on a few
issues Joe Biden doesn't really believe
anything so to say more moderate or more
radical would imply that he has beliefs
and he does and Joe Biden licks his
fingers figures out which way the wind
is blowing and then goes with that and
because the Democratic party is so much
more radical now and because RFK Jr I
think actually does have some beliefs he
seems more moderate and people just
think ah back in the 60s and 70s man
politics was a little more normal it was
crazy then too you know we were like
assassinating presidential candidates
and there was Cultural Revolution and
bombing Federal buildings but you know
though all in all it was more normal
than it is now that's the longing that
we're seeing and he represents that
because of his last
name and Trump and Biden for a lot of
Americans represent just the the modern
craziness now of course Nostalgia is
history after a few drinks so as I've
just alluded to the 1960s weren't all
that hot you know there were major
protests a ton of what is
euphemistically called civil unrest
which just means political violence the
assassination of major political figures
so it wasn't all that great Age of
Aquarius bunch of weird hippies croing
up doing drugs destroying the family all
sorts of stuff but people are nostalgic
and so how far can RFK Jr ride that
Nostalgia further and further depending
on how much the political order falls
into chaos which doesn't show any signs
of letting up doing that now speaking of
longing one of the biggest Halloween
costumes this year I am told I was
traveling on Halloween but I was getting
updates and I'm told that one of the big
Halloween costumes was Travis Kelce and
Taylor Swift and in fact Travis Kelce
was talking about this with his brother
Jason Kelce uh apparently they have a
podcast because every white man every
white Millennial man in the country if
not in the world has a natural right to
a podcast that I didn't I don't know how
that came to be but it just looking at
the results here I do not I'm I'm not
sure that I know a single white
Millennial man who does not have at
least one podcast so I guess the Kelsey
Brothers have one and they were talking
about how odd it is that people were
dressing up as this previously
relatively unknown football player and
Taylor Swift There were so many people
that dressed up Travis Taylor and me and
Kylie and mom like it was probably the
most um it was a Kel it was a Kelsey
Halloween that was a major amount of Kel
outfits it was a new heights it was a
Kelsey it was a it was uh pretty creepy
watching that many people be us but it
was awesome it's kind of cute I like I
don't know that much about Taylor Swift
I certainly don't know anything about
Travis Kelce it's kind of nice I don't
mind it it's it seems sort of relatively
wholesome America seems obsessed with
Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift just as
America is obsessed with all of Taylor
Swift's boyfriends which
shows a problem for for Taylor Swift and
her career and the problem is this
Taylor Swift cannot get married and move
on with her life without radically
changing her
career people love when Taylor Swift
gets a new
boyfriend but she needs to keep getting
a new boyfriend in order to do that all
of Taylor Swift's songs are just about
her ex-boyfriend so she needs a steady
supply of ex-boyfriends if she's going
to have a steady supply of songs and the
songs are popular and they've made her
into a
billionaire but the minute that she gets
a serious boyfriend and then gets
married and she's off the market what's
she going to write about what's she
going to sing about what are the
celebrity tabloid people going to follow
where's the surprise it's like a sitcom
this is the problem for sitcoms in a
sitcom you've got the two characters who
are love interests and the question is
always will they or won't they and then
the moment that they get together the
the show is terrible you want them to
get together you want to believe that
that there is true love and marriage and
a happy ending but the problem with a
sitcom is it's got to go on so it can't
that can't be the ending and then the
minute that you the viewer get what you
want in a sitcom the moment that Niles
and Daphne finally get
together The Show Goes stale because
there's nothing left there's no more
anticipation it's just now it's just a
marriage people don't want to watch a
marriage so what is she going to do this
is a big problem I think with our
culture is
we don't we don't want to move on we
want to remain perpetually adolescent
for our whole lives I think it's a big
part of why Taylor Swift's music remain
so popular I think it's a big part of
why the sitcom has been the defining
genre of the past 30 years I think it's
a big reason why people don't get
married and put put marriage aside for a
second why they don't grow up why you
have people in their 30s and 40s using
terms like adulting because they're so
proud that they paid a bill for once
but life is not a sitcom life is a
drama life is a drama and you've got to
lean in and grow and not be perpetually
a
child
now one thing that people have done
because they don't want to have babies
anymore they don't want to adopt if they
if they are not able to conceive on
their own they don't want to do this
they don't want to do that but so people
they treat dogs as children and that's
not good it's good to treat your dog as
a dog it's not good to treat your dog as
a child but when you do treat your dog
as a dog you want to give him the very
best food which is why you got to check
out Ruff greens right now go to Ruff
greens.com my stepbrother has been
giving his dog Ru greens and his dog is
loving it well the dog isn't loving it
because dogs don't have rational souls
and they're incapable of love but I am
sure that the dog finds the ru greens
appetizing and the ru greens are
definitely very good for the dog Health
naturopathic doct Dennis black the
founder of Ru greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food may as well be
considered dead food because it contains
very little nutritional value nutrition
isn't Brown it's green let rough greens
bring your dogs food back to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't even have to go out and buy new
dog food you can just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every single day
dog owners everywhere are raving about
it and Dr Dennis black right now is so
confident that Ruff greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering our
listeners a free jump start trial bag so
that your dog can try it get a free jump
trial bag delivered straight to your
door in just a few business days go to
Ruff greens.com m h a l or call 844
ruff1 123 that is r ufff greens.com or
you can call 844 ruff1 123 my favorite
comment yesterday is from Bill Burkett
7166 who says it's gotten a little hard
to watch the show with half of it cut
out all right listen man I feel you
there have been some cuts on the YouTube
show I mean I just do my show is the
thing because I'm not going to allow the
jerks at Big Tech to censor me from
saying what I'm going to say they can
shut my whole show down so we have to
clip out the parts that are not allowed
on certain platforms I think you know
which ones I'm talking about but the
full show is available it's available on
X formerly known as Twitter it's
available on dailywire.com for free for
everybody with ads it's available
without ads on dailywire.com for dw+
members it's available on Apple podcast
Stitcher Spotify I don't know what more
I can do for you unless you want me to
go in and change the largest company in
the world which has a liberal B I don't
know I'm doing my best for you but if
you want to watch that full show without
ads in the best way possible hear all
the things that big Tech doesn't want
you to hear you got to go to daily wi
plus and become a member speaking of
Human
Relationships Elon Musk has just said
that George
Soros hates Humanity Soros I don't know
I mean he had a very difficult
upbringing um and uh I in my opinion he
fundamentally hat Humanity that's my
opinion really yeah I mean well he's
doing things that erode the fabric of
civilization you know uh getting da
elected who refuse to prosecute crime
that's part of the problem in San
Francisco and la and a bunch of other
cities so why would you do that as is
often the case Elon Musk spot on here
this is the irony with humanists and
humanitarians is the humanists and the
humanitarian
they suggest that they are exalting
mankind that they are perfecting
humanity and all they want is for
Humanity to live up to its full
potential and the way they're going to
do that is by getting rid of all those
stupid things we believed in the past
we're going to get rid of religion that
only holds us back and makes us fight
each other and it's not very inclusive
and it's not diverse and Equitable or
whatever the modern jargon is we're
going to get rid of all the Traditions
we're going to get rid of all the normal
bonds and relationships we're going to
up in the whole world we're going to be
revolutionary But the irony is that the
humanists and the humanitarians end up
degrading human
beings when you when you have God in
your perspective and all the things that
go along with God religion civilization
inspiration when you have
that mankind becomes most perfectly
himself because man is made in the image
and likeness of God so when your Society
is oriented toward God you become more
perfectly who you really
are when you take God out of the
equation and you say we're going to be
humanists we're going to be we're going
to only focus on Humanity we're not
going to focus on all those other moral
or religious considerations and rights
and obligations we're just going to
focus on human beings humans are the
greatest thing of all we're going to
turn humans into Gods we're going to
write a book like yval Harari wrote
called homod
Deus ironically what you do is you
degrade humans because you're forgetting
what humans are supposed to be you're
forgetting who in whose image the humans
are made and so you make humans like
animals you make humans like computers
we start talking about humans like
machines or we start talking about
humans as no different from irrational
beasts we're just flesh we're just
hormones and synapses and pistons firing
we believe we pretend that we have
rational thought but we don't really we
know that that's just an illusion you're
just a cog you're just just a machine
you're like a computer we're going to
hack you you're going to have a hackable
we're going to biohack your body and
we're going to transform you we're going
to upgrade the software whatever stupid
language they use so ultimately they
degrade Humanity this has always been
the case it's always even George Soros
he's a tragic figure to me because the
thing I think of first when I think of
George Soros is Esperanto to me
Esperanto explains George Soros this is
a man who grew up his father was one of
the leaders of creating Tonto and
promoting it this this failed Universal
second language it's a language that was
just concocted it's a contrivance and it
was supposed to be the the second
language for all the people who speak
all these different languages that's how
they would all converse with one another
and we'd all come together Kumbaya and
the irony is there already was a
universal second language for thousands
of years in the west and that language
is Latin and it was precisely at the
time that all these new modern hip
liberal people said we got to get Latin
out of out of life we've got got to
latin's a dead language we got to forget
that all of a sudden it was exactly at
that time that they said hey wait we
need a universal second language so they
contrive this thing espiranto which is
just inhuman in fact if you try to teach
little kids to speak espiranto they they
will naturally make it more complicated
because life isn't so simple and and and
we human beings are just not that good
at playing God we're we're not we
actually can't create the universe
better than it was already
created and George Soros it a childhood
speaker of Esperanto and he is a big
promoter of it just as he's a big
promoter of all of these human
contrivances to remake the world after
our own image not going to work very
well very very degrading speaking of
humanitarians democrat representative
Jason Crowe is voting
against Republican speaker Mike
Johnson's Israel support bill because it
quote politicizes
Israel I'm not going to support this
bill it's a horrible horrible bill it's
horrible for Israel because it actually
doesn't have any humanitarian Aid
funding uh so like I've long said
there's no uh sole military solution to
this we have to couple humanitarian Aid
and protection of civilians with the
military response and if we don't do
that neither one of those will be a
success so there has to be humanitarian
funding but they have politicized this
effort to support Israel in a way that
is unacceptable it sets a precedent that
these National Security supplementals
will be subject to politics in a way
that we never have subjected in the
politics before and I'm just not going
to stand for it I'm going to stand up
and say there is a bipartisan way of
doing this in a way that we have always
done in the past and we're not going to
allow this to be
politicized the Republicans have
apparently politicized support for
Israel what does that mean what what on
Earth does that
mean how do you politicize a
congressionally ratified military aid
package to a foreign government was that
that wasn't political before what was it
that was just kind of cultural man you
know it was just artistic and spiritual
it was personal it wasn't political when
our duly elected representatives vote to
spend taxpayer money on a military aid
package to support a foreign nation in a
war that's not political give me a break
what that that is one of the phrases
that drives me craziest in modern
politics is when people
accuse their opponents of politicizing
something what does that mean political
means public that's all it
means if if an issue is of public
interest it is by definition a political
matter this one is just extremely
ridiculous because we're talking about
International diplomacy and foreign aid
well that was previously was not a
political matter I guess what he means
is he they're making it party political
they're making it partisan but like John
is not making it party political he's
saying hey we're going to vote to give
the Israeli government money you guys
want in and and a lot of Democrats are
saying no right now because it's a wedge
issue for the Democrats because the
Democrat donors support the state of
Israel and the Democrat base hates the
state of Israel so either way that the
Democrat representatives are damned if
they do and damned if they don't people
just
decry
politicization when they want to
delegitimize one's political opponents
when they say that's out your opinion is
outside the scope
of politics and of course they do that
often because they can't win a political
debate including at our internations
deliberative body you know my new
interview series Michael and takes a
deep dive into the world of
extraordinary people with gripping
testimonies from an exorcist detailing
what exorcism is really like to the
January 6th excuse me January 6 the
worst day in the history of this or any
Republic qanan chaman as he's called
describing his solitary confinement just
days after his release each episode
reveals something that you may not have
considered before in this latest
installment I sat down with a former
witch who warns that ridding oneself of
occult practices might mean the
difference between life and death
witchcraft in general is control and
manipulation is something that you do to
get some in return do witches worship
the moon especially during Halloween
that they believe that it opens up in
the spiritual this this was just
accepted as common place what are the
nuts and bolts of it like a demon came
and the main wi she just got possessed
and she started to speak someone in your
family is going to die in one week my
dad committed suicide and he was hanging
there this episode is now available on
the Michael NES Show YouTube channel or
you can listen to the Michael N Show
podcast pod on your preferred podcast
platform and now finally finally we've
arrived at my favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag this mail bag is brought to you
by palk go to Pur
talk.com toay I'm going to pull it up
here on my travel
iPad take it away hey Michael I'm a
longtime listener been listening since
my sophomore year high school currently
a freshman in college and I have not
missed a single episode since I started
watching um pretty big achievement in my
opinion ni so I'm in a little bit of a
interesting situation just for preface
I'm a male who has tracks into females
as long as well as uh males too and I
have a really good friend of mine best
friend I could ever ask for we started
off kind of just as like normal I'll see
you later type people and then shortly
after
um I didn't you know take this the way
it was at the time but develop some you
know feelings and um as far as I know I
know him pretty well as far as I know um
you know he's a straight male very
questionable straight male but you
know and it's just um rough you know
like since we're so close we basically
tell each other everything it's just
rough hearing him you know talk
about um this particular girl now who he
feels strongly for it's just really hard
you know not being able to um you know
tell them how I feel and uh just really
wanted some advice on it thanks there a
tough one
pal what I would recommend is don't tell
him how you
feel because look you're you're
obviously struggling with this uh you
are attracted to women but you you're
also dealing with some feelings of
same-sex attraction and this is
complicating your friendship uh it it
might be the case I I sometimes wonder
I'm not saying that there's
no uh deeper or more fundamental basis
of samex Attraction but the fact that it
appears to be so widespread now I do
wonder if that become is it partly due
to a confusion over friendship because
men
are
a when men become friends now it's it's
called gay if you have a friendship
that's any deeper than hey bro let's go
watch some strippers dance on the
sidelines in a football game while we
chicken wings and drink beer you know if
there's anything deeper going on then
people will mock you and say what you
talk about your deep thoughts and
feelings what are you a fuk you know
come on why don't you seem like a a gay
guy and then that's promoted in the
culture too so I think there's a real
confusion about friendship and I think
friendship is extraordinarily important
for men uh one might call it the highest
form of of relationship that's what some
of the ancient Greeks did they were a
little light and the loafers themselves
in certain practices but uh I wonder if
that's a little bit of the issue here
it's just the broader confusion about
friendship in this day and age uh you
mentioned that he's a questionable guy
so maybe maybe you're insinuating that
he might have similar feelings that you
do which is that he's attracted to women
but maybe he he could go the other way I
don't know some people say that
bisexuality so-called does not exist uh
I don't I just don't know I I mean
you're saying it does exist so I take
your word for it um and I don't know how
that comes about I would follow your gut
there and I would follow traditional
teaching and you've got a little bit of
an easier time than people who are
strictly attracted to people of the same
sex that's really hard for them
because what what are you what are you
going to do you could get married and
and just sort of you know grit your
teeth and barar close your eyes and
think of England or you could be
celibate though perhaps not everyone is
called to uh a vocation like that um but
that's a bit tougher whereas you say
well I am attracted to women I would
pursue that then I think that's probably
the right thing to do and uh if you're
going to be married and have a you know
sexual life and then I think I would if
I were you and you say well I like women
and I like men well I just ass soon go
for women then and you say well I like
my buddy I really really like my buddy
well okay then I I would really really
love your buddy as a friend I don't know
that that would it would be improved in
any way if you told your buddy you know
you like him is more than a
friend I I you know it's it's not um
well you're you're you listen to my show
and and you are writing in with this
question in in such a a sincere and
Earnest way that I think you know that
that that might be a hard lesson for
people who say but I've got this deeply
held desire or something but you know
our this is a fallen world and so our
desires can be become disordered and uh
in this case I would use your reason to
follow the the um right way of doing
things and then you then you can have
both then you can have a wife and you
can have your friend and you don't need
to confuse the two and cross the lines
and potentially blow up both
possibilities next question hi Michael
this is Kyle uh big time fan of the show
uh first time voicemail bag really
appreciate you keeping me up to date on
the news uh one news story in particular
was the one about seed oils um while I
thought I ate clean I uh didn't realize
how ubiquitous seed oils really were I
had to even cut out my favorite brand of
Olives that being said my question to
you is what type of political solution
is there for seed oils and you know
broader scale obesity given that you
know the seed oil have influenced or
greatly like greatly pushed up obesity
rates and that's affected you know
military recruitment laziness etc etc
you know do you ever see uh you know
maybe a major politician say Ronda
santis uh Vic whatever um ever coming
out against seed oils or you know
reforming those Industries what type of
uh political Solutions do you see thanks
for all you do it's funny you mentioned
V I could I could see him bringing up
seed oils because he he's the more
eccentric edgy candidate in the GOP
Primary so I don't see Trump bringing it
up I don't D santis is in some ways a
little more online and a little edgier
than Trump but I don't I think he's
still too mainstream and established as
a sitting Governor to do that but I
could totally see V bringing up the seed
oil thing uh and it it's the seed oil
thing is the
first big diet fad as an adult that I I
bought into I used to be really
skeptical of it and then sweet little
Alisa totally seed oil peeled me and I I
buy it and I my sun sunburns are not as
bad anymore so you know there's that uh
but the answer answer is the answer to
the seed oil problem is spend a lot more
money on food that's it that's why the
seed oils are in everything because
they're super cheap and right now we
have very high inflation and we've got
in particular inflation among food so
what's the answer if you're doing well
you know if my blank book sells some
extra copies this Christmas then I have
no problem we can sweet little Laisa can
go buy the most expensive seed oil stuff
in the world and we'll get fewer
sunburns but for a lot of people who are
hurting in this economy it's just an
issue of money so you could try to
regulate it I suppose I'm not opposed to
just and prudent regulation by the
proper authorities you know most local
as can be if possible um I'm fine with
that but it's not really going to solve
the problem because the problem is
really a financial one that's what
started the seed oil Trend in the first
place next question Hey Dirty Mike Mr
reality here I wanted to ask you to
elaborate on your thoughts from
Tuesday's show regarding Israel bombing
part of of a church campus not on that
specific church but rather on whether
churches in general should be safe
havens for terrorists to plan acts of
evil throughout Eastern Roman history
tyrants would often try to take refuge
in churches to escape Justice only to be
dragged out to face that Justice in the
modern era terrorists use churches and
other religious buildings as well as
hospitals schools and so on as places to
conduct evil and relative safety there
seem to be three options for a nation
being victimized by these evildoers one
ignore them and let them carry out their
evil two sacrifice the lives of their
own soldiers to try to preserve the
building or three bomb the building to
destroy the evil I agree that it is sad
when historical artifacts especially
churches are destroyed in war but it
seems wrong to suggest a nation
victimized by terrorists should
sacrifice more of its citizens lives to
avoid damaging buildings that the
terrorists are profaning do you think
churches should be off limits that a
victimized Nation should sacrifice its
own blood to avoid damaging churches or
do you have a different perspective I
have suggested thanks the issue with the
church in St poros is is not as you
describe it I guess is is why I would
call out that
particular
bombing no one is alleging that St
pereria Church in Gaza was housing
Islamic militants or that Hamas had
built tunnels underneath this
church in fact the Israeli air strike
was apparently or I guess I think that
was yes that was an Israeli air strike
it's sometimes confusing because
sometimes the air strikes or the the
Rockets or the bombs come from the
Palestinian side and then they blame
Israel and then Israel blames the
Palestinians and then you find out later
in the fog of War what really happened
but in that case it looked like it was
the state of Israel sent a missile next
to the church because near the church
that's where the terrorists were hiding
and it destroyed part of the church
because of that and so I don't I don't
begrudge the state of Israel defending
itself and killing terrorists and
obliterating Hamas obviously not but in
that particular
case it's a it's a real shame because
the the church was built by Crusaders in
the 11th or 12th century and it dates
back parts of it date back all the way
to Antiquity so it's just a real loss
for part of the church to be destroyed
and I'm I'm not suggesting that uh we
need to make Idols out of historical
buildings especially
churches uh but we can be a little
careful you know even at the height of
the second world war the the Nazis the
axis and the Allies decided not to
destroy Paris they could have destroyed
Paris but they didn't destroy Paris that
was good and so I just think that uh
There are rules to war and there are
special considerations to be made in war
and war is a war is a bloody killing
thing to quote General Patton you know
there's there's no way of getting out of
it in a really nice way uh but
combatants can
observe uh certain niceties and
accommodations for for how to keep
living and how to how to maintain
culture after the war so that that was
an issue there I don't think the state
of Israel intentionally tried to blow up
a church or anything like that but uh
one can go in and obliterate and kill
the enemy while having some constraint
in cultural consideration and at the
height of that one should have
consideration for for churches all right
next question hey Michael uh really big
fan here I have a quick question for you
you're always posting videos on YouTube
reacting to uh fat phobic or Tik tokers
complaining about fat phob I and you
encourage physical fitness and stuff
like that uh two-part question one do
you work out and second if the answer is
no uh when are you going to start
slamming some protein and uh lifting
some heavy circles
thanks yeah that voice sounds strikingly
familiar to me sounds a lot like the
voice of one Professor Jacob
H well Professor Jacob over there thinks
just cuz he's lifted few weights he Mr
Beefcake gets to push us all around huh
gets to bully us and tells us to go hit
the gym huh
yeah all right that's our show I'm
Michael N this the Michael Noll show see
you next
[Music]
week